ganz deutschland hallo erst mal ich habe
vor zwei wochen ein video auf youtube
gesehen namens bill gates of new york
kim kardashian ging es darum dass eine
unangenehme fragen gestellt werden
entweder man beantwortet diese
unangenehme frage mit der wahrheit oder
man muss etwas ekelhaft das essen
beziehungsweise trinken
ich fand diese idee relativ cool und
habe mir gedacht hey wir kommen einfach
mal ein paar youtuber zusammen und
stellen uns gegenseitig recht
unangenehme fragen allerdings ist das
bei uns komplett eskaliert
wir haben uns im laufe des videos nur
noch fragen gestellt die nicht
jugendfrei waren deswegen wenn ich euch
jetzt gleich das video zeige was wir
aufgenommen haben werde ich einige
fragen die einfach zu weit gingen mit
anderen fragen eher übertonen ich hoffe
ihr versteht das sonst wird dieses video
definitiv runtergenommen oder ab 18
gesetzt und jetzt an der stelle viel
spaß
wir haben keine kosten gescheut ich wenn
es euch mal ganz kurz ein diese ganzen
produkte haben wir heute im supermarkt
tatsächlich gekauft und daraus ein
tolles trinken bastelt doch mal kurz
riechen ja das ist alles mit dabei sind
die wirte mal eine person sitzen und
hinter der kamera werden dieser person
fragen gestellt und zwar keine normalen
fragen sondern wirklich unangenehme
fragen wo man wirklich in erwägung
ziehen könnte einen schluck von diesem
getränk zu sich zu führen wie er direkt
mal kennt ihr ja schon holen als klar
ist da alles lacht willst du jemals
freunde deiner ex freundin alles klar
dass du kannst du eigentlich überhaupt
nicht nein jetzt gerade hier jetzt
gerade hier ja wie ich bin so
empfänglich war sowas nicht daran ich
konnte schon nach dunkel zu positionen
er ist ein extrem damals ja wow
studierst du weil youtube nicht so gut
läuft
nein sagt die wahrheit
heißt sascha ich habe eigentlich ein
oder hast du schon mal über einen sex in
unter sechs tagen gekommen
für die abonnenten der mitmenschen nicht
gesehen ziemlich abstoßend dass du dir
schon mal mehr als zweimal am tag eine
unter geburt ja menschen in der zeit
madrid mit juni zusammen bisher gab es
schon mal einen moment wo es so schütte
oder ein spiel davor war dass du mit
nachdem romas touristen dass du von
allen beteiligten im raum den besten
style hast thomas selber nachdenken über
landungen fragen ja fragst du da ein
paar oder dann machen wir lieber schöne
grüße aus der kohle gibt
hast du schon mal wenn es nichts gewusst
willst du dir manchmal das ist single
wärst was zu essen gemacht
klasse einer person zur begrüßung die
hand gegeben gab es schon mal einen
monat wurde mehr als drei euro verdient
hast ja ich hab's mir doch mehr als drei
euro verdient hast hier werde man sagt
schon wäsche gewaschen
ja das ist schon hart ist als ins video
waren zu schneiden
just im moment wo du einfach reif wenn
dieser beträgt die fresse schlagen heute
sahst du hast es dann auch kümmert so
gerne wie vor schäden reparieren ja noch
das klima für familien und gesagt dass
du nico heißt ist ein dummkopf was wir
in den vergangenen sechs monaten die
hose geschissen nein bist du schon mal
feld begannen nein
mehrere von der polizei angehalten
worden wegen der auto ja und was es noch
nie eine schulische einrichtung besucht
würde ich in deinem kopf ein gehirn
gefunden
nach welchen von dezember mitgliedern
hast du am meisten oder abreißen kann es
ja nicht mehr am markt am wenigsten auf
euch jungs mussten auch jeder sind
gleich zu gerne kuba nein nein nein
also schnell lieber ganz kurzen werden
informationen darin befindet sich tragen
sind
hast du jemals selbst über eine frau
ausgespielt ja was man blumen gepflückt
ja rosen veilchen ein kakteen nein was
schon schwimmbad
was heißt das ob ich dann entspannen bin
ich war deine hausaufgaben nicht gemacht
und ist dem lehrer zu sagen ja
hätten wir jetzt doch schwimmbad das was
wir schon einen mann mit zunge geküsst
nein was du schon eine frau ist kleine
rohde vom allen youtube in deutschland
welche findest du am hässlichsten kenne
ja nicht alle doch von allen jetzt von
meiner empfindung hier
ich sage nichts regelung ab morgen keine
wirklich über die würdest würdest du es
noch machen
oh mein gott ist mit der länge dann ist
zufrieden wie lange also es war es
wirklich nötig die praxis wieder alles
klar
max cooler typ
das ist schon mal eine straftat begangen
es hat die wir heute habe ich das ist
schön
hattest du schon wohnt im haus seiner
eltern dir deine zähne mit zahnseide
gereinigt 18 bist du dir mehr als zwei
mal in die hose geschissen frage gut
trinken was wäre ist eine frage über den
betrieb muss dann fragt ihr die freiheit
warum ich bei anger ausgezogen werden
kann man darauf kommen
hast du jemals eine ex-freundin von dir
auf den mund geküsst und schlüsselszene
doch was trinken ja ok luca das was ihr
vom video das war's jetzt ihr vom video
hier können jetzt jemanden kanal
abonnieren oder hier unten meinen job
aus checken jetzt findet ihr zwei andere
videos und wenn ihr schon abonnent seid
könnt ihr auch die glocke klicken dann
willkommen die benachrichtigungen